[Music]
i am so proud to be a chinatown native
and such an advocate for the
neighborhood because i feel like it is
such a vibrant community
that's so rich in history and built by
the backbone of immigrants
[Music]
kkdiscount has been around for over 30
years and throughout that time my
parents were able to develop a
relationship with not just the locals
but the businesses in the area literally
if you walk down the street with them
everyone would know them chinatown is a
community everyone just knows each other
and other shops in chinatown other
mom-and-pop shops they all have similar
relationships with everyone it's
something that
i think really truly makes chinatown who
they are because there's there's a lot
of stories that are similar to my my
parents and myself well my dad he was
like a knight in chinese armor he he
came here first and then within a year
he immigrated here with my mom they
decided to make chinatown their home
because
it felt like a piece of hong kong to
them from the familiar language to the
familiar smell of food they just felt
that this was
a place that they can make their home
and what they envisioned their future to
be
they didn't have any money they didn't
have family here but they felt confident
that chinatown was a place for them to
live out their american dream
i'm so happy i have my
my store with my wife and my daughter
and now i am like my granddaughter this
is a family small family business but
this is my goal the dream you can say
come true yeah
when my parents opened up kk discount
that was when i actually started working
at the store and by working i mean
literally manning the outside part of
the the shop where i would be selling
sponges and shopping carts and that was
literally my
weekend program my my after school
program like there was no such thing as
soccer practice for me my after school
program was being at the store when the
pandemic happened
we had almost no idea of what was going
to happen with the store and
that honestly made it really hard for me
because
the story is his life
you know and and he worked so hard
to
um
make his dream come true and all of a
sudden this this virus
is going to shift down the store and
despite all that my dad was able to
basically see the light at the end of
the tunnel he knew to take it one day at
a time
unfortunately a lot of businesses did
not survive even on the street of kk
discount they were at a minimum of three
to five shops that didn't last through
covid and so
a part of me felt that this must be it
because no one's coming down to
chinatown anymore and
thankfully we have a lot of non-profit
organizations coming to chinatown to
help focus on how we can amplify the
businesses here and the voices here and
make it more than just a food
destination that there is so much here
that the neighborhood can offer
then chinatown love's main mission is to
provide coveted relief for asian-owned
small businesses across new york city
it has been such a huge honor and
pleasure to meet and work with the small
businesses that we do there's just so
much more that meets the eye we work
with a handful of restaurants that all
sell similar things but their individual
stories and reasons for coming to this
country are so different being able to
talk to them hear them has not only
given me a unique opportunity to give
back to them but has also added so much
meaning to my experience here as an
asian american
one day
my daughter was just at the store and
she was you know moving inventory for my
dad
and by the end of five minutes she
literally had an audience
watching her and then clapping for her
when she was done so
that just gave me the immediate idea
that you know what having her
have it social media and showing what
it's like being in a mom and pop store
is is really interesting to people
so little miss chinatown is all about
driving traffic to chinatown and letting
people know what it's like growing up
and living and being in chinatown native
oh yeah my daughter helped me a lot from
a little miss time because they come i
can get more new customer we need to
continue the business we need the new
generation to come down here
it's actually been inspirational to
watch
businesses try new things and that's
exactly what norina and her family did
they are trying
social media for the first time they're
using websites for the first time and
i'm seeing that same energy across
chinatown too where restaurants who were
cash only are now doing delivery apps
and gift shops who were only ever
selling to locals are now looking into
online stores
small businesses make chinatown
chinatown
by having streets lined with mom and pop
shops they really keep the cultural
richness that has been around in
chinatown for decades because
we are small community they have so many
small businesses we need to help each
other
i'm just one story but every mom and pop
shop that you see in chinatown has their
own story that's very similar to mine
and so it just means so much to me to be
a part of this neighborhood
meeting people like narina has given me
hope and optimism for chinatown and as
long as that neighborhood is expanding
in their hands our future for chinatown
will be so bright
[Music]
my name is riya i'm a content creator at
buzzfeed my grandma used to run a
business in my hometown in japan she
used to own a diner
so i used to hang out at a restaurant
all the time so i'm kind of like your
daughter okay
i think it's great like you know helping
out i think those kind of little things
like interacting like older generation
definitely helped my communication
skills working at the store
really made me who i am today and given
me the identity that i have now
thank you so much for sharing your story
and experience with us
since you've done so much for your
community we would like to give you
something dao is sending you three
thousand dollars so you can continue all
the amazing work you are doing oh my god
thank you i mean i
and you might not be received i'm kind
of blushing right now and thanks to zeld
the money will be in your bank account
in minutes oh wow that is fast thank you
zell so much i appreciate it i mean it
means a lot and yeah and i am so glad
that we were able to talk and connect
and just very shocked and happy and
all these mixed emotions and i cannot
wait to tell my parents about it thank
you zell